mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
they say one percent can solve this
problem
you need to select three of the balls
and place them in the circles such that
the numbers on the balls have a sum of
30. you're allowed to use a number more
than once but you must use exactly three
of the balls
this problem was sent to me by email and
there are many popular variations of
this puzzle across the internet i
thought this was a fun variation i
wanted to share
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall the rules of parity
an even number plus or minus an even
number will always be an even number
an even number plus or minus an odd
number will always be an odd number
finally an odd number plus or minus an
odd number will always be an even number
in this problem we're only dealing with
sums in particular we want the sum of
three odd numbers
to get that we'll add an odd number to
both sides of the very last equation
we end up with the result of an even
number plus an odd number which we know
from the second rule is equal to an odd
number
therefore the sum of three odd numbers
will always be an odd number
so how can we get three numbers to have
a sum of 30 if we're limited to the odd
numbers from 1 to 15. we can't it's
mathematically impossible
but this is not strictly a mathematical
problem this is a puzzle
so what's the trick
the clue is that the balls have the same
colors as billiard balls take a look at
the green colored ball
we can orient it in three dimensional
space
in particular you might know the trivia
that the green colored ball in a
standard set of billiard balls is the
number six we turn the nine upside down
to get the even number six
we then solve the puzzle by adding the
numbers eleven and thirteen
six plus eleven plus thirteen is equal
to thirty and that's the answer to this
puzzle
there's an important lesson
when a problem seems impossible try
changing your perspective
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you